[Musique]
elle s'appelle mireille et pour la
première fois elle se promène dans
montpellier à genoux découvert on
apprécie en connaisseur
on se retourne en curieux qu'en
pense-t-on au fil des rues sept mois de
cours d'être vraiment bien lorsque les
lions notre jolie jambe sinon mais sinon
il y en a qui ne sont pas si bien fait
est parfaite
alors là c'est la catastrophe pour elle
et vous mademoiselle que pensez vous de
cette manne
les jupes très courte moi je la trouve
jolie peut-être originalement fait je ne
la porterai sûrement pas pourquoi elle
est un petit peu trop excentrique à mon
goût et bien moi je pense que c'est une
mode très joli mais surtout jolie pour
les jeunes filles
parce que si des personnes un peu plus
âgés ou plus mal fait importer bien je
crois qu'on aura des drôles de surprises
et ma foi ça sera pas toujours un
spectacle très heureux mais pour pour
des jeunes filles c'est très bien
mireille l'ampleur chez les joueurs de
pétanque qui ont la normale
[Musique]
je me trouve le couillon il me sort elle
connaîtra des parties de jeu
je me régale à moi perso c'est très bien
parce que avant on mettait des jupes de
courtrai jeunes filles pour les jouer au
tennis maintenant et bien le son est
toute prête pas au tennis prix de plus
comme vous voulez voir des jolies jambes
il faut le faire semblant de se lasser
le soulier tandis que madonna n'est ce
pas par un simple petit mouvement on
peut voir si on a affaire à du vrai du
faux dans des motels cependant tél enfin
c'est très bien on est tous accros les
gouvernants même relayé voyez il en rit
parce que eux aussi vont pouvoir
profiter de la chose vie à la jupe
courte noire et j'ai peut être eu cours
de celle des suivants si elle avait les
jambes ou auprès d'un jeune il ya des
personnes à qui ça va et d'autres
personnes qui se laisse un peu léger de
quoi pas grave il faut pas mettre tout
le monde à poil
évidemment c'est une opinion extrême
[Musique]
mireille à la sortie de l'école êtes
vous content madame bon jusqu'au bout
oui c'est pas les vous plaît ça me plaît
oui enfin mireille dans les vignes
c'était indispensable a de l'amour
[Musique]